DAVID HARBOUR
I've gotta be honest, I'm pretty excited
about joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as Red Guardian.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
You're officially a superhero!
You've got the suit.
ALEXEI SHOSTAKOV
[Grunts] Still fits.
DAVID HARBOUR
That is true.
FLORENCE PUGH
And you have the superhuman strength.
DAVID HARBOUR
That is also true.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
You've got that unbridled charisma.
DAVID HARBOUR
Well, you know, I mean... [Laughs]
I guess you can say, Red Guardian
is like the Russian Captain America.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
I mean, you could say that.
FLORENCE PUGH
Yeah, we wouldn't say that, but you could.
DAVID HARBOUR
Good!
I will say it! I'm the Russian...